so what the saints wanted to do
they wanted the browns to sign genevieve
and clowny because the browns lead the
nfl in cap space right now and the
browns would have signed clowney the
browns would have paid
a large portion of his salary like the
texans did last year when they unloaded
clowney's contract onto the seahawks and
then the browns would have traded
clowney to the saints for a draft pick
and a player
and look when you consider these other
trades that have been done on the
surface there should be nothing wrong
with that there should be no problem
with it but
the saints ran it by the league office
chris
and the league office said we're not
going to allow now one of the factors
may have been this weird chain of covet
19 protocols who knows maybe in a normal
year the league would have said okay
but that was one of the concerns okay so
if the browns sign this guy he has to
show up here and sign a contract he has
to be in a hotel for a couple of days
and have three negative covert 19 tests
before he signs his contract then we
turn around and trade him to the saints
and he's got to go sit in a hotel for
three days and get three negative covert
19 tests and then what if something goes
haywire what happens is he on the browns
how does this work i think that was part
of the practical concern okay i still
don't know why the league wouldn't allow
it though that's what i why would the
league allow it it's an arm's length
transaction it's creativity in action
why not let it go through i i mean i i
don't have an answer for you i was
hoping you were going to have something
for me here just to say like why but i i
don't get it either
what what is the thing that would hold
it back as far as
it's still trading commodities right and
you're still
staying within the guidelines of the
salary cap and
draft picks are tradable that way so i
don't really understand it either i have
a hard time believing that it would be
the coven 19 thing that's an interesting
like angle i didn't really think about
that mike you know yeah maybe does that
delay the process even longer but i
would still like so what you know if
you're the new orleans saints and you
want your deviant gladney you want your
deviant clownie like the hell with it
okay he's got to sit in cleveland for
two days fine then he'll come here and
sit in three days maybe he can't play
week one so i'll have to play the next
you know 15 games after that but uh i i
was shocked to hear that as well you
know that that that wouldn't go down
like why
why is that so much different than brock
osweiler with the houston texans what
makes it that much different
it isn't different because what the
browns did was they bought a draft
picture i traded caps basin cash for a
draft pick when you send the player plus
the draft pick to unload his cash
obligation and his cap space that's
exactly what you're doing now maybe this
was just too transparent maybe it would
have been too bang bang
of a move one other wrinkle too before i
i move on in that explanation
what if clowney had passed a very
perfunctory physical in cleveland
because they don't care they're not
putting him on the field and then he
goes to new orleans and he fails the
physical there what happened he's a
member of the browns right right he's a
member of the browns i mean that's part
of the risk you take but but i i think
that there is a way to do this i was
talking to somebody about this yesterday
there's a way to pull this off
if it's not compressed like this and
maybe sometimes you know what's the old
saying it's better to ask forgiveness
than ask permission maybe the flaw was
they bothered to ask the league if the
league would allow it you know maybe if
you just do it maybe if you just do it
right yeah if you just do it they've got
no way to to say no hey we've signed a
player okay you've signed a player
contract approved hey we're trading the
player okay you're trading the player
contract and trade approved what are
they going to say no so i think they
should have just done it maybe that
would have been the way to do it don't
ask for permission just do the damn
thing now the other way to pull this off
and and i think it's given teams
something to think about now for the
future you go into an off season where
you know from the get-go one team
doesn't have cash and doesn't have cap
space another team has cap space to burn
right right what you do is and it's
going to take two general managers who
trust each other very completely and
thoroughly and it's going to take an
agent who's in the middle brokering all
of this who everyone trusts but what you
do is in march
that's when the team with the caps base
signs the player
and then in july that's when they trade
the player and no one's gonna say boo
about it then so that's the way you pull
it off you just number one it's hard to
pull it off in a day and number two if
you ask the league ahead of time
for basically an advisory opinion on
whether or not it's okay they're going
to be inclined to say no because they'd
rather you not do it i think that's the
key i don't know that it's impermissible
i just don't think the league wanted him
to do it so if the league says i don't
we don't know about this and it scares
them off mission accomplished yeah i
guess so i mean the other thing i just
think about you know the fact is
you know just trading a draft pick by
itself can that happen are you allowed
to do that just trade addre that's where
i guess
it's different from houston because you
had osweiler yes they wanted to trade
him the browns are going to take them
they had a little bit of a need for the
quarterback backup position so that made
sense now yeah the contract was
expensive so here's a draft pick to go
along with it you know to take away the
contract of the player and all that to
ease the pain
i you know i i will say i don't think
i've ever heard just a draft pick being
traded that way right where you just
trade like hey here's the draft pick now
we've traded you the pick can you sign
the player
and
you know take some of the money off of
his contract and then trade him you know
back to us i guess maybe is i don't know
is there something there the fact that
deviant clown is a free agent that
changes the language of what can be done
as compared to brock osweiler who at the
time was under contract with the houston
texans i mean i'm hoping we'll have
answers about this kind of stuff by the
end of the day but i don't know yeah
look look look at what look at what
happened last year yeah the texans have
the franchise tender applied to david
clowney yeah he hadn't signed it yet
he's a free agent he's not employed by
the texans right so in one fell swoop he
signs the tender
and the texans pay seven million dollars
of what he's due to make
and
and then they trade him to the seahawks
right so
right the seahawks
are they gained contractual
control over him there before they at
least made the move to where maybe they
knew where it was going i know but maybe
i'm just
i know i'm with you mike i get it i'm
just saying maybe it's a leak arguing
he's not under any contractual control
right here and you can't trade him that
way or therefore he's not a commodity of
either team i i don't i don't understand
it either i don't know i don't know i'm
just trying i think that i think the fly
in the ointment here was that the saints
decided to ask
for permission instead of just
doing it and when you're hey you want to
be aggressive go do it did baltimore ask
two though did they ask the league or do
they just hear what the saints yeah okay
that that's that's the next yeah that's
the next wrinkle in this and this is
what we caught wind of yesterday and
it's funny because you know i'm in my
let's find something really good for the
thursday night chiefs texans pregame
show nugget that i can mention during
the the uh you know the time that we're
on the air right and and uh my my nugget
thursday night was going to be it was
actually the ravens that would have
gotten him if this thing were deemed to
be permissible not the saints that would
have been the ultimate switcheroo for
the saints if the league had said yeah
go ahead and do it the ravens were the
ones who were going to do it the jaguars
would have signed clowney and traded him
to the ravens that's how it would have
played out under that scenario for a
variety of reasons and i once i found
out about it yesterday
and and felt very confident about it i i
came to the realization that there's no
way it was going to hold until thursday
you just get a sense of how many people
know and too many people knew so we went
with it yesterday and uh yeah it's the
100 truth the ravens would have done it
and boy the saints would have been
pissed right they do all the leg work
they put in the elbow grease they call
the league the league says okay and then
go somewhere else and go somewhere else
under that same scenario but uh yeah the
jag and here's why the jaguars would
have done it they don't want clowney in
their division this would have been
perfect it keeps them from going to the
titans it's the ultimate way to block
clowney from becoming a titan the
jaguars become the facilitators of
getting clowney to the baltimore ravens
it's genius and i think they just should
have done it just do it and don't ask
anybody if you can yeah no i'm with you
i understand the jaguars doing it i mean
they're kind of you know like we've seen
but they're they're collecting draft
picks and assets that way it does make a
lot of sense i'll be interested to hear
i would think we're going to get some
sort of statement from the nfl this week
on why that was blocked right i mean
somebody's going to have to come out to
come out with that and i'll be
interested to hear what that reasoning
is i mean holy cow clowny to the ravens
i mean already the best roster in
football and now you put him with those
you know big mean angry front seven that
would have been some from some defense
holy cow
remember we talked about that last week
yes remember i told you that they were
in quietly on yannick and gawkway and
what if we wake up one day and they have
clowney and you did the whatever that
thing yeah you do that mind blown emoji
yeah yeah right yeah so uh anyway
uh it's uh it's it's interesting to see
why
it happened and what the and i'm going
to find out i'm going to find out that's
a challenge i'm taking that as a
challenge from you christopher david
sims i'm going to find out exactly why
the please do do your job hurry up
figure it out holy crap it's tuesday
afternoon i mean tuesday morning you
don't have the answers to this i mean
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from nbc
sports